nevada ranks last in the nation for
distributing the coronavirus vaccine
hopefully that's going to start to
change through the week bianca holman is
live this morning at cashman center
where staff are going to begin
administering medicine again
today bianca good morning
hey good morning john so cashman center
is our southern nevada's
largest vaccination distribution site
matter of fact its first week
they gave out 15 000 doses but this past
weekend they were closed they're going
to be reopening
this morning now it's important to note
that you must have an appointment to
come and get your shot
you also have to be eligible if you are
eligible you are a person who is 70
years or older a front line health care
worker
public safety personnel community
support including teachers now
an online tracker by bloomberg news
shows that nevada is
50th in the nation for vaccination rates
less than 5 out of every 100 people have
gotten a shot so far
by comparison now alaska leads the way
with nearly
13 percent of population vaccinated
officials here say the biggest issue is
lack of supply so there's a temporary
shortage
and they're asking everyone to remain
patient in the meantime
and of course in addition to this side
here at cashman there are other sites
around the valley that are doing the
vaccinations there's the smith's
pharmacies there is the encore resort
and then there is also
the southern nevada health district
we've got all this information on our
website
if you qualify or are eligible right now
to receive the vaccine
reporting live from cashman center
bianca holman 8 news now